have you ever wondered how much power
the Queen Ashley had type this question
into Google and you'll read that oh the
world family is just a ceremonial
position it's just for tradition they
don't have any actual power they just do
a bunch of ribbon cutting
[Music]
when in reality that is just what they
want you to think see wow they distract
you with oh look at how this sweet old
lady smiles and waves look at how pretty
the princess is let's watch her wedding
while you were distracted with all that
the queen and the Royal Family actually
have an insane amount of power and an
unimaginable amount of wealth she could
veto and change any laws she pleased she
could bomb Nations she could literally
get away with murder not an exaggeration
she had enough money and power to make
any super villain drool from the mouth
even Donald Trump looks scared of her
but you'll never hear about any of this
because the world family is smart they
keep all of this on a Down Low they make
sure the public really does believe
that's all ceremonial why because these
people don't pay taxes they spend their
20 million a year allowance on vacations
and home renovations they accept bribes
in exchange for favors they can
literally get away with murder so of
course they want you to think it's just
a ceremonial position these people are
immune above the lot and they want to
keep it that way and now King Charles
III has taken her throne along with all
that sweet power so the question remains
how much power do they really have stay
dangerous and let's get into it
[Music]
thank you
if you want to be super successful you
gotta look at what the most successful
people are doing like Zuckerberg and
Steve Jobs who wear the same outfit
every single day to cut down on the
number of decisions they have to make
they do this and I do this because it
works you just have to find clothes you
feel great wearing every single day and
luckily that is where Bessie comes in
Bessie makes these super light
breathable 100 waterproof shoes and I
absolutely love them because these shoes
can take on anything while looking good
I tortured the last pair I had with
music festivals traveling dirt rain mud
for like two years straight and they
were still going strong what I love
about them is that they can take all of
this abuse while being super versatile I
can wear them to the gym when I meet new
people when I'm out and about and
traveling in the summer or winter since
they're super stretchy you can slip them
on and off super easily and there's free
shipping returns and exchanges so if you
want some of the most versatile shoes
out there vesi is giving you guys 25 off
when you go to vesti.com Jake Tran and
use code jtran at checkout so pause the
video and go to vesti.com we're called
Jake Tran for 25 off now thanks to the
Vesti for watching this video
every queen or King of England will
enjoy what we call sovereign immunity
this basically means that they have a
forever get out of jail free card
meaning they're immune to all types of
criminal charges including yes murder
other members of the monarchy are only
immune from civil proceedings you know
mine are things like getting sued issues
with the landlord contract breaches but
they are still able to be charged in
criminal cases not the queen she is the
personification of the crown and when
you go on trial in a commonwealth
country you are defending yourself
against the crown aka the queen if the
queen was ever put on trial she would
just be going up against herself and
that wouldn't make any sense now would
it to top this off the queen also has
diplomatic immunity which means she
cannot be charged under the laws of a
country outside of the Commonwealth
either she was basically a free agent in
this crazy game of life and if she wants
to drop a bomb on your house she can do
it and suffer no consequences to further
add to the Mayhem she can kill or
arrange to have someone killed and never
have to share any information about it
or who was involved because of her legal
exemption from information requests now
that is a lot of power
[Music]
so the queen has a permanent get out of
jail free card but what other powers
does she wield
you may not be aware of this but before
a new law can even be discussed in
Parliament the queen or Prince of Wales
needs to give consent first the Queen's
consent which requires she give her
consent before any law that affects the
interests of the monarchy can even be
discussed at all in Parliament so unless
they think it's a good idea it's not
even going to be talked about they also
have the power to veto any bill that
they don't really like enter the White
Hall papers
a list of 39 bills released in 2012 that
were either vetoed or revised by the
queen or Prince it included bills like
the 1996 Housing Act the 2004 Higher
Education Act and the 1999 military
actions against Iraq bill in the UK
military strikes on Iraq had to be
authorized by the Monarch not the
Parliament and this bill was trying to
change that needless to say the queen
vetoed it right away it seems she wanted
to keep this power to drop the bombs
herself save it for a rainy day right it
turns out that many of the bills listed
in the White Hall papers that the queen
vetoed or had a heavy hand in were all
related to either her personal wealth or
the wealth of the extended monarchy the
because nothing gets between the queen
and her private purse
[Music]
money and power go together like uh
trumpets and jam and the royal family
just can't seem to get enough the crown
currently owns one-sixth of the earth's
land mass and when we put the valuation
of all the monarchy's combined assets
together crown jewels included we get to
an estimated total of 88 billion dollars
most of this money is inherited and gets
passed on from one Royal to the next
completely tax-free by the way just
another medieval law that they're still
benefiting from the rest of the money
comes from income gathered from the
crown estate which is land in the UK
that the family personally owns
government grants AKA money from the
British taxpayers and another kind of
shady source which we're gonna save for
later in the video every year the royal
family receives a grant from the
government to use at their own will as
long as it generally supports the
service of the queen this can include
anything from garden parties to
Vacations so basically British citizens
pay the royal family an allowance that
they can use for almost whatever they
please
2012 the annual Grant was the equivalent
of 36 million dollars U.S and in 2018 it
went up to 96 million imagine if you got
nearly a hundred million dollars a year
as an allowance why are they getting so
much free money from the people well
this grant was actually negotiated a
couple centuries ago by King George III
he hatched a deal where he will give all
the profits from his crown land to the
government in perpetuity in exchange for
a yearly salary that will support his
lifestyle and the relief of all of his
current debt which he seemed to have a
lot of so the ownership of the Crown
Land was passed over to the UK
government but you know what's coming
over the last century different Royals
including Prince Charles have done
everything they can to get the profits
from the crown estate back into their
own pockets and it wasn't until a man
named George Osborne became Chancellor
that the prince's request was finally
put through just like that now the royal
family gets 25 percent of the profits
from the crown estate that's a 144
million dollars a year now going to the
royal family instead of the British
people while they still get that yearly
allowance
Harry and Megan have also had their
greedy moments when they made the
decision to move out of Kensington
Palace and into a nearby Cottage 3.4
million dollars was requested from the
government to pay for the renovations
before they moved in so the British
people are putting in all this work
paying their taxes so these two can
renovate a cottage while acting like
they are the real victims
well played there have been tons of
cases where the monarchy squeezed the
taxpayer where it already hurts but
there's another way the Royals monetize
on their status that's a little more
under the table
thank you
this is Prince Charles he's not the most
popular Royal but foreign businessmen
love him in February of this year Prince
Charles was accused of accepting a 1.7
million dollar donation to his charity
from a Saudi Arabian billionaire in
exchange for a Knighthood which would
translate to UK citizenship so a Saudi
Arabian billionaire basically bribed him
1.7 million dollars in exchange for
citizenship when the prince was
questioned by the media on what he had
done he gave the same response all
guilty Royals give quote the prince had
no knowledge of the alleged offer of
honors or British citizenship on the
basis of donation to his Charities end
quote kind of reminds me of someone else
I know I have no recollection of ever
meeting this lady
to cover himself the prince launched a
formal investigation of his charity by
his company the prince's foundation and
found that his longtime assistant and
friend Michael Fawcett was the one who
coordinated the transaction now the
prince is being brought in as a witness
in a crime that he almost definitely
committed himself
whenever Prince Charles is courted on
something someone else Falls in their
sword Prince Charles has also sold seats
at Royal lunches one Turkish billionaire
paid Prince Charles 230 thousand dollars
processed through his charity to avoid
tax of course so that his wife could sit
next to him at a dinner party so if you
see someone sitting next to a royal they
might not be all that important just
someone who knows how to legally bribe
them
up until 1973 Prince Charles received a
hundred silver Shillings and a pound of
peppercorns like the literal pepper
seasoning from the mayor of Launceston
every year because it was a law that was
placed centuries ago does he need a
pound of peppercorns probably not but
you'll notice that the royal family
seems overly obsessed with holding on to
tradition in the way they dress the way
they talk the way they sip their tea and
it's all because they're clinging onto
the power and wealth that was randomly
bestowed onto them over a thousand years
ago
if they don't if they become too modern
they might inspire a reform in the
monarchy and that would mean less power
and less money
foreign
[Music]
if the queen has all this power why
didn't she go full on Tyrant why didn't
she rule with an iron fist well because
times have changed Optics matter if the
royal family wants to maintain all their
Priceless perks they can't rock the boat
they need to keep their image spotless
they need to voluntarily pay some taxes
because if they didn't the masses would
start seeing them as a ticking Time Bomb
they would revolt and that would be
really bad news for the monarchy
so instead the queen worked quietly
behind the scenes doing everything she
could to make sure the public was okay
with keeping her family at the top of
the hierarchy this woman had the power
to fire any prime minister drop a bomb
on any country release any prisoner from
jail kill any man without consequence
and dissolve an entire Parliament if she
really wanted to and now all of that
power has been passed on to this guy and
you'd better believe he will do whatever
it takes to keep his family in power
and while Prince Charles does his Dirty
Work behind the scenes his brother
Andrew continues to cover up his
friendship with our sex trafficking
Golden Boy every japstein
besides prince Andrew many powerful men
have had evidence leaked of their
connection to Epstein including Donald
Trump Bill Clinton and one of Epstein's
most loyal clients Les Wexner the CEO of
Victoria's Secret what would a
billionaire sex trafficker want with a
company that employs beautiful fit
teenage lingerie models well lots of
things but these things are way too
risque to reveal in a normal video we
would get demonetized almost instantly
which is why we decided to release all
of this information as a private
uncensored full-length documentary only
available to members of this Channel all
you have to do to get instant access to
the Victoria's Secret Epstein connection
and tons of other secret docs on topics
like Monsanto MK Ultra ncia black sites
is to click the join button below and
unlike University we are not going to
charge you thousands of dollars only to
leave you in the dark about how the
world really works all it takes is five
dollars a month to learn what they'll
never teach you in school and there's a
refund policy too unlike most YouTube
memberships so if you're not happy with
the membership just email us within your
first month of joining and we will
refund your five dollars right away no
questions asked after your first month
there is no refund
wouldn't it be nice to be considered
royalty and get a giant allowance and
not pay taxes I sure would enjoy that
but what do you guys think about the
queen and the Royal Family do you like
them are you fans do you think they're
outdated let me know in the comments
below and if you're new here this is one
of the biggest channels on YouTube for
documentaries on money power war and
crime just like this video where we
teach you how the world really works so
if you enjoyed this one click that
subscribe button below you can follow me
on Instagram jakestram but that's going
to wrap it up State Angels out there and
I will see you guys in the next one
thank you